the more than just flickering images on
a screen drug public service
announcements have been a part of your
life and a part of your nightmares for
decades join us as we count down 5 drug
PSAs that try to scare the [ __ ] out of
us but really didn't it any questions
number 5 is this is your brain on eggs
the drug could be good brain on drugs
if this late 80s ad brought to you by
the partnership for a drug-free America
didn't scare you may be the follow-up
containing your scary alpha male dad
dead this is your brain this is drugs
this is your brain on drugs
Yad was also remade about a decade later
this is your brain except this time with
scary tank tops and this is Harold it's
not over yet this is what your family
goes any questions number four is doctor
recommended psychedelic cartoons it's
stimulating it's the in thing the who
brought the jet generation this one is
from the American Medical Association in
the 1960s and to really understand the
irony of its message you're gonna want
to take a few bong rips and turn out the
lights
the human brain after all is made for
thinking not fumigating it's hardly a
tinker toy for experimenting with drugs
it's use can lead to abnormal behavior
to psychological dependence and to abuse
our other drugs number three who taught
you how to drug
taught you to do this stuff you all
right I learned it by watching you
parents who use drugs have children who
use drugs there isn't much to say about
this one do you already know it's stupid
people have been making parodies of the
ad for years who taught you how to use
this thing I learned it from watching
you who gave you these who taught you
about these I learned it from you okay
number two is mr. t chokes the drugs out
of us little kids doing drugs it turns
my stomach
oh that spilled milk mr. t hurts to use
them it hurts just family that's gonna
be like a hundred pounds of bling there
it's a wonder his neck doesn't fall off
hey it hurts his friends I just want to
check some systems you know you can
think about you get you for your memo
don't or else
yeah sorry tea but you're aggressive
tactics didn't stop kids from getting
hooked on the junk but let's hope
another message you made did number one
is peewee cracks us up this is crack
rock cocaine yes pee-wee herman of
pee-wee's playhouse the guy whose show
felt like a dorm room acid trip with its
talkin chairs genies and dinosaurs which
bets the question is this character
really the best pitchman for the war on
drugs everybody wants to be cool but
doing it with crack isn't just wrong
it'd be dead wrong so if peewee taught
us anything about drugs
I don't know sorry guys I took a few
puffs watching those pee-wee's Playhouse
clips and that's five we hope we didn't
scare you too much if you aren't high as
a kite by now post some links to more
drug the essays in the comment section
below
[Music]